I want to turn out of the ridiculous
double standards President Trump is
facing this time its inauguration
funding again squeeze squeeze squeeze
this practice has never fallen under
such scrutiny five fund the inauguration
but this supposed latest blockbuster
investigation gives liberals the
narrative that the walls are closing in
so the president has nowhere to turn no
where to go well here's something you
might not know back in 2013 special
interest contributed 40 percent that's
almost half of the funds for Obama's
second inauguration here with reaction
is Ari Fleischer former White House
press secretary to Bush 43 and Robert
wolf Obama mega donor former economic
adviser to his 2012 campaign and someone
who donated money to the 2012 camp
for Barack Obama Ari is this scrutiny
warranted or is this a clear-cut case of
a double standard here well on the
surface it surely seems to be a double
standard you know the investigation of
Hillary was never a real investigation
of her and now we have numerous
investigations of Donald Trump from
agency that just probably never wanted
Donald Trump to be elected in the first
place and that's troubling now I don't
like to draw conclusions like that about
justice because I was raised to believe
justice is blind and it must be blind
but you know we haven't heard from
justice yet on this these were leaks
into the newspapers about an
investigation it's not yet confirmed and
the focus is on foreign contributions
and given to straw men who donated
that's a different matter and that
should be investigated but I haven't
seen any evidence that anybody in Trump
world did anything wrong well in Robert
you were a big donor to President Obama
and look I don't think I I think the
campaign finance laws are
unconstitutional may say that till the
cows come home you should be able to
give as much money as you want as long
as it's disclosed to anyone or your own
money shouldn't matter okay but anybody
you should be able to give whatever long
as you disclose it so I have no problem
that your big donor Obama but Obama
swore off special interests in in the
first inauguration but then took
corporate money lobbyist money teachers
unions
all sorts of Union money came to the
campaign came to the inauguration big
deal what's the difference here okay so
we should just take a step back one I
think your premise is inaccurate on a
double standard otherwise george w bush
took from the same type of people that
obama took in thirteen I don't think
we're talking about corporate money here
I think to our ease point the whole idea
is were there foreign interests that
gave which is illegal and secondly Obama
didn't have an Obama Hotel which is
there's a lot of scrutiny so if you want
to go back on where corporate interest
started I think in 2005 in the
inauguration Obama took from the same
people that George W Bush took so I
don't think it's about corporate I think
we're talking about where any law is
broken and by the way I'm not saying any
laws were broken I'm just saying I think
that's what they're looking at not a
fishing expedition it's a complete
fishing expedition I'm going to tell you
why because Hillary Clinton's foundation
bill Hillary Clinton's foundation
received money from Saudi Arabia Kuwait
Qatar Oman Australia Norway Dominican
Republic Algeria and how much Algeria
gave but and you know suddenly all that
money starts drying up when mrs. Clinton
is no longer Secretary of State and
she's no longer clearly going to be
president of the United States all that
money went away now do you think re that
money was donated clinton foundation to
get access and can you imagine donors
get access in the obama world or all the
people going to these parties and obama
administration they're the ones getting
access welcome to washington i I can't
imagine why people don't want to
continue to get access to mrs. Clinton
either why didn't they stop giving money
oh I guess he's not running for anything
anymore
of course Laura but let me address a
broad point here and your guests made
the point about the hotel you know one
of the things that's just so unusual and
different about Donald Trump to his
credit and he's a businessman he came
from a hotel industry all the laws and
all the rules are set up to make it easy
for career politicians to stay in
Congress to stay in government and
therefore you never had a conflict
because you don't own anything in the
real world along comes business people
and it's almost impossible for them to
run because people try to make a
mountain out of nothing so what the
people are staying in his hotel he's
already said he's not making the profits
from it he's divorced from that from the
Trump company as the president but so
what if the Trump corporation is making
money from it it is America's private
sector and I want people from the
private sector to be able to run for
office well let me just respond one
I'm all for capitalism I ran a bank and
for that hat was in 49 states 27
countries now we gave to the iron sea we
gave to the DNC Phil Gramm was my
vice-chairman okay so I have no int with
Donald Trump doing amazingly well
actually UBS or you know did business
with Donald Trump we're talking about
today and we're talking about did the
inauguration committee okay do something
illegal or not and Laura let me just
finish for someone but there's nothing
wrong be spending money at his say by
the way you do a my saying anything's
wrong with that I'm saying that's what
they're looking at well you raised it
well you brought it I raised it because
it was on the front page of two papers
that's another question
how did that happen to come out given
the fact that the inaugural committee
itself Tom Barrett they've never heard
of any investigation they haven't been
asked for any documents they haven't
been interviewed I'm not in suddenly
this is leaking out of the Southern
District of New York
I find the Southern District of New York
the most leaky federal prosecutor office
they were outside my office for five
years I'm all there yeah you know
Stephanie Wolkoff keep that keep that
name front and center because she was
hurt her company was paid a lot of money
she made good money off that
inauguration but a lot of these big
party companies do and stuff like that
all right guys thanks so much